But yeah, no, it was it was just like
never ending like digital war. Like you
could like that you could tell they all
think that they're like these digital
foot soldiers.
>> [laughter]
>> I got to say a lot a lot of slurs. Like
I mean slurs, you guys. Uh the bad ones,
like the very very bad ones. Lot of
slurs. Yeah, I I do agree that criticism
of you Hutch will feel like targeted
harassment because you are a narcissist.
>> [music]
>> Maybe you want to check out that Ogre
Boy video that Hutch put out.
I thought maybe that might be funny.
Let me see. Let me see.
Here's where we arrive at something that
I want to focus on. Ogre Boy, I know
you're watching this, buddy. Pay
attention to this part, okay? There were
people coming into the chat on Livin'
Learn spamming stuff about my dead
sister. And uh ladies and gentlemen, we
got them. Oh my god. This was when they
were still putting the chat on the
Livin' Learn and someone was spamming
and they were jumping between different
channels.
>> Mhm. Immediately I'm like, this is
[__] up. And then I went over to the
the alleged snark server and I was like,
this better not be any of you people.
Like like don't even tell me that it's
one of you. Come on, bud. You know I
have the logs and I can
Uh then show the logs of anybody saying
they were doing that?
Does he Does he show the logs here or
he's going to stand on this and say, oh
you know I have the logs? I can read the
Like that's very different than somebody
who is saying that [__]
Who is Perry? If Perry was right? But
I'm pretty sure nobody's done that.
That's uh that's a no no no no no no no.
>> whole conversation. Like you know that.
Why are you lying about this? Not true.
He did not say that. And I had like
three people immediately respond like,
I'm not doing it. It's not any of us.
And then that was it. Also not true.
And by the time I looked back cuz I was
on Also not true.
Oh, okay. Then can Hutch show that? My
phone, by the time I looked back, they
did they'd already banned the person and
it had stopped. Also not true.
Everything about that is a lie. To my
knowledge, it wasn't coming from anybody
that I was aware of.
Just like bald-faced lie. But the way
that you really own these people is like
go out in your communities, go volunteer
at a soup kitchen. There's one more
person that I want to Never mind.
[clears throat] in terms of how they're
reacting to this story and it's just
it's too good. I know Listen, I'm
violating a policy. I'm temporarily
violating a policy that I've had for
for months. We're going to temporarily
pause the no ogre boy policy cuz he
When have you
ever When has he ever held Hutch, you
don't have the self-discipline to hold
to any policy. Just don't don't make
policies, man.
You, Destiny, the same guy. You don't
have the self-discipline to maintain
anything you say like that. Why Why even
try it? He was spending a little bit of
time talking about this on his stream
and I would like to unpack it with you
guys cuz
I did catch a few minutes of it and boy
are there some doozies. It's good. It's
real good. by anyone in any server. He
thinks this is funny. They all think
this is essentially funny. It's just
that Destiny is trying to paint this is
this is something that's affecting his
court case. He's trying to stretch this
out. He's trying to like pull the
timeline backwards far enough to try to
suggest that the people in this server
have something to do with what is going
on with like his court case, with a lot
of these
>> commentary on that from Hutch. He needs
a new victor. He needs a new aggressor
to point at. Did he get a Oh. Is that
true? Yeah. [clears throat]
Is that true? Wou- Would you even Would
Hutch even entertain the possibility
that that could be true? Like will he
actually entertain it or is he going to
totally fake entertaining it? He's like
a
He's like a duplicitous compromised
dude.
I think it's just the fake part. We'll
see. Maybe it's probably just the fake
part, but maybe. True.
Genuinely, is that true? Has he Has
Destiny been referring to the Snark
Discord as something that has to do with
his court case? I haven't heard that.
Have you guys heard
Uh
Wait.
Has he not implied that that Discord
like proves something about me or
somebody else to do with his court case?
Has he not done that?
>> heard that? Does anyone know what he's
talking about? He has discussed his
deposition on stream, but that's not
what I'm saying. He's saying that Oger
boy is saying that the the Discord the
Destiny is framing it as as the the
Discord is like
Oh, yeah. He said that they're sending
the people in that Discord are sending
arguments to opposing counsel.
That's what he said.
Right.
Yes.
with his court case or something like
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no,
no, no, no, he has Oh, no, no, no, but
Destiny has said that the people in that
Discord are sending arguments to
opposing counsel, right? And he can
prove that. Did he not say this? Almost
like I think he said this verbatim.
May Well, we'd have to find the exact
wording, but he said something very much
like this. like that. Uh some actors
involved in both. He's claimed that J
Stalk and some of these other people
have been feeding information to Pixie's
defense. Oh, I see. All of the things
that have happened to me are because of
these people. That's what he's doing.
So, uh but we'll get to that. Now,
meanwhile, everyone else
I don't think that's true. I think
that's overstating it just a little bit.
while everyone else
So, uh but we'll get to that. Now,
meanwhile, everyone else
I don't think that's true. I think
that's overstating it just a little bit.
Wait, why is this 480p?
This is basically a new
>> overstating it? Hold on. What is
overstating it?
>> these people. That's what he's doing. I
see. All of the things that have
happened to me are because of these
people. That's what he's doing.
So, uh but we'll get to that. Now, That
is absolutely what he's doing, and Hutch
is like Like directionally, that's 100%
what he's doing. Come on, man. Come man.
>> I don't think that's true. I think
that's overstating it just a little bit.
None of us can like let's be honest
about what this is.
Let's let's really dive in here.
None of us feel like we can do anything,
whether it's a Democrat or a Republican
administration, to actually change the
course of what's going on. Even if we
voted super duper hard,
all you can do is vote hard, participate
in your communities,
Dude, no no argument, no conversation.
He just makes faces. This just makes
faces. It's all he can do.
No argument, no content, no nothing.
Right? Hey, Hutch. He's He's trying to
make an argument about how much you
could contribute to politics as somebody
who's a commentator. Do you have any
thoughts on that or are you just going
to make stupid faces?
Try to do advocacy and then hope for the
best and hope that maybe even if it's
This person
>> Sam Seder talked about why he was okay,
even though he's not an
anarco-communist, why he worked with an
anarco-communist. Because he wants a a
broad left.
He just admitted that he doesn't think
individuals can impact
>> Oh, I I thought he was going to make his
own argument. He's actually just reading
somebody else's argument. Okay.
So, he sits back and he makes faces. He
waits for a chatter to make his
arguments for him so he can read them
and go, "Oh, yeah, baby. Oh, yeah,
maybe. Maybe that's the way it is." act
our government. This is obviously an
outlet to give him the feeling of
control over his Well, yeah, I think
he's very explicitly like laying this
out. But also like
I do tell my chat that they should you
know, some people should tamp down their
expectations. Like
I I don't think it's reasonable
to think that like medical Medicare for
all is like a good example of this. Like
that policy
is just nowhere near the kind of support
that it needs in Congress to pass. Like
a some kind of single-payer policy.
Public Does this not So, I'd have to
look at the polling on this. I'm I'm
unaware of what the policy is.
Regardless, it doesn't mean you can't
push for the policy. Doesn't mean it's
like stupid to push for the policy,
right?
You do need the right story to tell
around it. You could run on it. Right?
Like I'm trying to think, there are
probably some other policies that
wouldn't have like broad support if you
just polled with with just them laid out
the way they are, right? Anyway, we keep
going.
>> Option, yes, but not Medicare for all.
We're just not close to that. And so,
for those people, I do say, if you're
going into a new administration, like if
you went into the Biden administration,
he's sworn in in January 2021, and and
you're going in there thinking like,
"Oh, maybe we can get single payer." And
then that didn't happen, and then you're
pissed about that. You caused that.
You inserted your own unrealistic
expectations of things, and because
those things didn't happen, you're
pissed, but you did that to yourself.
Like you caused that anger by going into
something with wildly unrealistic
expectations. And this is a principle
that can apply to every part of your
life. This is a universal principle. You
should check your expectations in your
own personal life, maybe with your
career, with your partner. Okay.
That's like
your internal expectations can be lower.
You don't need to not push for
aspirational things, right? Like I'm
totally fine with yeah, with like
lowering Like that's a good path to
personal happiness. I don't know if
that's a good path to political change,
right? Like if if black people are
slaves and you're just telling them
like, "Hey, maybe just like
we could give you like an hour off each
day or something."
Right? It's It's like, dude, there's
probably like a fundamental injustice
going on here. Not that I think there's
a similar level of injustice happening
in American society right now. It's just
obvious that
sometimes it's not enough. Sometimes you
should message more aggressively.
I don't think messaging You shouldn't
have
You shouldn't have discipline in what
you're willing to push for. You should
have discipline in what you're expecting
personally, by my opinion.
Your husband, your wife, your kids, your
friends, your family, like if you start
imposing your expectations on other
people and then they don't meet them and
then you cop a resentment over that,
they didn't do that, you did. Like you
don't accept that they are the way that
they are.
I wish it wasn't Hutch so transparently
just giving us the things his therapist
has told him.
You know what I mean? Like I just
Unfortunately, that's like a complex
thought that is actually valid and
intelligent. And so I know that that's
just him reiterating what his therapist
has told him. Like I know he didn't come
up with that. Whenever Hutch gives you a
valid like complex intelligent thought,
you can automatically go, "Oh, who'd you
get that one from?"
Or you don't accept that things are the
way that they are.
And so you're making yourself angry. I
mean like so I say stuff like something
like this, which, you know, I think that
is just such a
like an obvious thing that people should
think about. But very often times people
like AugurBoy will will
will describe that kind of
idea as
me saying better things are not
possible.
But I'm not saying that. I'm saying
better things are possible. I'm saying
better things happen all the time. A lot
of better things happened when Biden was
president. You should want better
things. You should ask your politicians
to do better things, to make better
decisions, and create better is not what
Dude, rhetoric is not How many times do
you have to get absolutely obliterated
by the orange liar that prompt that
over-promises
for you to go, "Oh, maybe some soaring
rhetoric would be appropriate." Like how
many times? How many times you got to
get by this orange liar before you're
like, "Oh, maybe I could like, you know,
push for something bigger and then we'll
try to do the best we can and we'll see
what happens."
We never thought about that, have we?
No, just get keep getting asked by the
orange the the fat orange man. Okay.
better outcomes. Like of course I
believe in that.
But, you know,
I
Apparently, this was all projection on
his part because he thinks that you're
basically just like Uh I do like this
Marty FC. He calls it reasonable
expectations but he's actually
describing cynicism and giving up. Most
people who advocate for more radical
ideas already know the probability of
success is low. That doesn't mean you
don't try. Yeah, exactly. There's a
saying that everybody knows you shoot
for the star you shoot for the moon you
land amongst the stars, right? As in you
should have aggressive targets and you
should push for them understanding that
they're aggressive targets, right?
They're your North Star and if basically
you just want a target where if you get
somewhere like halfway
the world's better.
There you go. Why is my
powerless to influence anything. That's
what he's saying here. So And he wants
to try to move the needle and he thinks
that like the things he wants to see we
might not get there in his lifetime but
he wants to try cuz that's what you need
to do.
Right?
So we don't think that we can affect
anything really in our government but
you want some kind of catharsis. And if
I don't think that. I think you can
affect your government. [laughter]
I think I think you can you know
accomplish a lot of things. I think you
can create movements that lead to like
very real change. Is he not just
basically saying he wants an
acknowledgement from people in power
that like this is important pushing
these directions are important? That's
depressing to hear.
>> go back and listen to Oger Boy without
the audio.
>> This is good advice for life but not for
politics.
You should put reasonable expectations
on people you bring into power and
disown them if they don't fulfill
reasonable is the key part. Well, that's
what I'm saying. You're making my point.
That's my point. You you should be
reasonable. You can be aspirational and
and you can push for things that maybe
you suspect are not possible in the
short term with the hopes that maybe you
can find a middle ground that's like
>> What is this? Why did Why did I get sent
this timestamp?
It sounds like a joke but I'm not even
kidding, right? Like
Here's my
unironic advice for people that are
getting into American politics, okay?
Expect less.
Wow, you did it for me. Scale your
expectations
down. This is unironically how you just
let fascists with actual soaring
rhetoric take over your country.
Don't listen to this bald he doesn't
know how to convince anybody of
anything. The only audience he has is
because he's beholden to other people.
Off.
>> Closer to your goal like all that's
fine, but if you're going into an
election thinking that like literally
everything is on the table and then when
when the biggest
boldest parts of your policy platform,
your preferred platform, when those
things don't happen and if you get
really pissed it's like well you did
that. You did that to yourself. You did
that. It wasn't Biden who, you know,
like caused this anger with if you went
into Biden's presidency thinking he
could do like the New Deal 2.0 with a
50/50 Senate, well you did that to
yourself, man.
That's something that they teach you a
lot in recovery spaces.
Like resentments are a big part of Dude,
I'm so dude, it's so [__] up that this
guy is like a transparent book. It's so
[__] up. Now like I'm telling you the
expectation thing that's just
transparently from his therapist, yes,
his counselor, yes. I it's so [__]
man. I don't
I want to be wrong about this guy one
time. Do you know what I mean? On a
personal level. I could be wrong with
the direction he's going with an
argument. He doesn't have a very linear
thought process to me, but in terms of
what he's describing himself or what he
thinks
and recovery like Oh, sorry, in a
personal way. Sobriety, Alcoholics
Anonymous,
Narcotics Anonymous, a big part of that
program, of those programs are unpacking
your resentments. You one of the steps
is you you're literally writing down
like everyone and everything that you
have a resentment towards.
And then ultimately what you learn with
the help of a sponsor
is that for many of these things you're
causing that pain yourself. And then
you're using that pain to
justify drinking or doing substances.
And so it's just like self-perpetuating
spiral.
Of causing your own pain and then and
then you're running to substances to
numb the pain. So, Hutch would rather
have like totally morally reprehensible
people around him who go, "Hutch, you're
really smart and valid." Right? Hutch
would love Hitler over his mom if his
mom was mean to him and Hitler went,
"Hutch, you're you're smart and valid."
Right? Like that's I'm obviously being a
little extreme, but that is who Hutch
is. Hutch would much rather have
somebody who's like kind to him and
tells him he's doing a good job than
anybody who's honest with him and
anybody who is like real with him and
helps him improve.
That is who Hutch is. Fundamentally at
its core. Ogerboy right now, trying to
make arguments, has always engaged has
always engaged with Hutch, has always
directly engaged with the arguments,
right? But now Ogerboy's being a little
bit mean and Hutch is like, "Oh, you're
being mean? That means you're wrong."
No, it doesn't, Hutch. It turns out
there are ways that people could
disagree with you or think you're a a
[__] and be correct. Many ways. I yap,
I play videos, I snark on these sons of
and by that I mean just be critical.
That's snark is the new critical. And
then that's it.
I take snark to mean like
targeted harassment, you know? Yeah, cuz
you're
Yeah, I I know that you take you take
criticism as targeted harassment.
That's what you do.
Nobody started calling this snarking
until you guys started crying about it.
We were just being critical the whole
time. Being critical with a comma
comical and and negative lens or sorry,
how should I put it? Vitriolic lens,
right? But it is comedy. The criticisms
are real. You just can't disambiguate
the criticisms from the like mean
commentary, the mean jokes around it
because you have a you're a tiny man.
You have a large ego and you're a tiny
man. You can't handle it.
So, like you could say, "Oh, well, I
take it to be targeted harassment."
Yeah, I I do agree that criticism of
you, Hutch, will feel like targeted
harassment because you are a narcissist.
I can't wait for the Snarker files. Oh,
I'm sure they're coming. I'm sure
they're come I'm sure they'll be made
public at some point. This was a Dude,
I'm I'm actually confident that Hutch
doesn't realize that he doesn't know. He
goes, "I have the logs. You guys are
lying."
I actually think he's just lying.
When when Ogerboy says, "No, no, no, I
asked if anybody did it and a bunch of
people said, 'No.'"
Right? I feel like Hutch doesn't know
that the logs are there to show this.
Like he just has no idea. You know what
I'm saying?
Like he has no clue that's the case.
A 24/7
surveillance operation.
Get over your self. That's crazy.
That's crazy.
It's true. I mean, listen, there's a bit
of hyperbole here. They were focused
Like they watch the content you
broadcast as a part of your job. Like I
have a 20 If I watch HBO for a couple
hours in the evening, I have a 24/7
surveillance operation on HBO? Are you
out of your mind? Don, like a lot of
people. It wasn't just me and I was not
I was not even close to the the amount
of attention that that people like um
Ethan and Destiny got, but
they were the point was like there was
always someone like chatting in the
Discord. Like there was all there was
just just a never-ending conversation
and they're all like
targeting this creator and that creator
and this creator and that creator and
Okay, differentiate this from any
Discord that's made around content
creators or content creation.
There's always somebody chatting in the
Discord. They're always watching
something.
Y- Yeah. Again, um DGG chat's my
favorite comparison. It's like
Tell me when DGG chat doesn't have a
stream on. They always do. Of course
they do.
Like what are we talking about? What are
we doing here?
What
Oh, that's a question for Och. Can you
differentiate any of your criticisms
from the DGG community?
Nah, there were like there were like
sometimes where they were like more
focused on me than other times and but
uh but yeah, no, it was it was just like
never-ending
like digital war. Like you could like
that you could tell they all think that
they're like these digital foot
soldiers. No, those are the other team.
That's the other team. You know,
fighting for
Hasan [__] and against these
like evil
uh liberals and Destiny orbiters and uh
Zionists and uh
it's basically exactly what you would
imagine. Why not just put your logs out
that show anything you're saying?
Based on their behavior. Just just just
imagine what that would look like in a
Discord server. And yeah, it probably
looks exactly like that. Okay, first of
all, you don't stream 24/7. What do you
mean?
What do you mean?
And He really took me literally on that
one.
>> Okay. Oh, no. If somebody says I've been
surveilled 24/7 and you don't know them,
what does that sound like to you? What
does that sound like they're saying?
We have had a strictly enforced no ogre
boy policy for several months now. I'm
breaking it today because this video is
just
incredible. But I'll go on and show you
the number of times that he without me
even mentioning it, that he brings me up
on his stream. He wanted in December, he
was talking out of the blue without me
knowing it because Filmon's always like
2 weeks behind.
>> [clears throat]
>> He turned around and was like
What is Filmon by the way? What is that?
Some kind of transcription service? What
What is this? We should bring Is he
transcribing all of my streams and then
control F'ing for ogre boy? Is that what
is happening? Of course You You know
what you could do?
Hold on. How hard is it to open a tab
and go Filmon? Oh, Filmot. Oh.
Search within YouTube subtitles,
captions, and transcripts.
Why would you think you have to even do
anything? Like literally, you could just
search this stuff. Like Hutch's has been
on there for like
years now.
Since the site opened. Like I It's so
weird that he thinks this is the case.
>> it is.
Why am I even questioning that?
Obviously, yes. Jesus Christ. Ogre boy
over
What What Filmot does is it search It
basically downloads the transcripts for
all the videos on a channel.
And it will index them so you could
search them in aggregate, right?
That's basically what Hutch But Hutch
doesn't understand that.
Right? So, he thinks people are watching
all of his streams, all of his old
content to find old moments. He doesn't
understand there's a website that's
indexed his entire channel with nobody
doing anything, nobody doing anything
special, right? But they've indexed his
entire channel, all the transcripts from
it, and you can just search.
So, he just doesn't know any of this.
So, he's coming on stream, uh very much
like his political takes.
Completely uninformed.
Talking out of his ass, very
confidently, making stupid faces when
other people say [__] when they actually
have information.
And he's embarrassing himself.
Just a classic everyday Hutch stream,
really.
>> You know, and that'll be content. He is
your Joker. He lost all his friends and
wants your proximity. This is, you know,
it is like a Joker origin story, and
this is the
Now I feel like I'm being mean. Why do I
Why do I Why do I do this? Why do I do
this?
Why Why Why do I do this? I am a nice
person. I I swear to you, I'm a nice
person. Of all the origin stories of
like an anti-fan. Absolutely not. You're
like a whiny piece of [__]
Total cry bully.
You're not a good person.
Pisco's a good person.
Pisco's standing up for you, and even
when you came in, kind of steered him in
a conversation. Even when you did that,
he didn't go, "Oh, you, Hutch." Right?
He went, "Oh, I didn't realize. I'm
going to fix this for you, Hutch." Like
Hutch did not reciprocate. Hutch would
refuse to reciprocate. His entire mod
staff let Pesco get trashed for their
entire argument.
He never once went, "Oh guys, be nice to
Pesco." Even though he says that, he's
just lying. It's all there on the tape,
Hutch. Why do you lie? Don't lie. I'm
pretty sure I don't want to get into
like what kind of behavior this this
like transparent pathological lying is,
but it's not good.
This is
definitely the saddest one that I've
ever heard in my life.
It sounds like he had a dedicated a
dedicated group of friends that he
played a video game with. And then come
to find out it wasn't a real friendship
because he realized they didn't they
didn't really like him. They just liked
playing the game.
And so then there was like an emptiness
inside of
This every friendship, by the way. This
is like 99.9% of your friendships.
You're a an adult you realize this. That
like the reason you have best friends in
like in school, in primary school, in
middle school, in elementary school, uh
well, sorry, high school I meant. Um
the reason you have these friends cuz
you're together all the time, right?
Like proximity is what puts you
together. It takes a lot of concerted
effort to maintain friendships over
distance.
It just does.
I don't know. Does Hutch not realize
that?
I don't know I don't know how you would
fail to realize that, to be honest with
you. with him. Like he fills with his
searing hatred of me. I just don't I
just don't know what to do with that.
That that's But
he's
Hold on. Actually, why am I saying it? I
want to drive the point home. Here.
Here. Here. Here. Hold on. Let's take a
walk down memory lane for a moment here,
shall we? Because I want to set the
tone. He's trying to make it out
100%
This is a
This was a star surveillance operation.
What am I even looking at? belmont.com
search ogre boy. Does he have some kind
of an automated website? I'm assuming
that's what this is, where you automate
to like monitor people's streams? Or is
this just monitoring everyone's streams?
I don't even know what I'm looking at
here. Search within YouTube subtitles,
captions, and and transcripts. And he's
just search it's just a broad search. It
searches like the whole internet.
He's like looking so desperately
>> [laughter]
>> to search that it's actually shocking.
Oh my god, a website exists on the
internet where you can search me?
Oh my god. Dude, he's like the guy from
Gremlins.
Oh my god.
They're eating me, and then they're
going to eat her. Oh my god. Dude.
Some kind of an automated website? I'm
assuming that's what this is, where you
automate to like Oh, you're right.
You're right. You're right. My bad.
>> monitor people's streams? Or is this
just monitoring everyone's streams? I
don't even know what I'm looking at
here. Search within YouTube subtitles,
captions, and and transcripts. And he's
just search it's just a broad search. It
searches like the whole internet.
He's just He doesn't even like
It basically like is you're not
downloading anything to your computer.
And for Hutch's channel,
as far as Ogerboy's concerned, Hutch's
channel's just been indexed for a long
time. This is the funny thing. It's like
once all of this is explained, you
understand that Hutch's whole thing
about being surveilled 24/7 entirely
falls apart the moment he doesn't
understand what Film Mod is.
Like
So, what Hutch thought was happening
is Hutch thought people were watching
all of his old videos, everything he's
ever done,
to try to find anything they could use
in a video against him.
He doesn't realize that like so, by the
way, everybody in DGG, everybody who's
on the
side, this utter
[__]
This fantastic [__] has
come into this video. He's trying to
tell you that these people are stalking
me. They're finding videos from like 10
years ago. Oh my god. And he is unaware
that you could just search the
transcripts. He is a totally unreliable
person. He is totally out of his depth
trying to talk about this. And he's
basically lying to slander other people
to create a permission structure to dox
them. So, thank you, Hutch, for coming
into this whole situation, ignorant like
you normally do, and causing harm like
you normally do, you bald
searching the whole internet.
I'm being a little mean right now, but I
think it'll make sense here in a minute.
He doesn't stream on Saturdays. What is
he doing?
What is he doing? You don't have to be
this hyper
bro. Hold on. We have to just Hold on.
He's been mentioning me just as much as
anything else. What do we call this?
Like weaponized ignorance or weaponized
stupidity? Like taking me literally and
being like, "What do you mean we monitor
you 24/7? You don't even stream on
Saturdays." Like what is this? Like
weaponized stupidity? No sick day.
There's literally nothing wrong with
watching Hutch's stream. Again, just
making [__] up.
>> days 7 days a week. He doesn't stream on
Saturdays. What is he doing?
What is he doing? You don't have to be
this hyperbolic, you
shing my ass. Oh, so he knows it's
hyperbole, and he's like laughing at you
for being a whiny [__]
He identified that that's the criticism
criticism, Hutch, that you're a whiny
[__]
every move. I did
$20,000. I did, yes.
You know, I thought
No, he didn't.
No, that's a meme.
And I'm so bummed that he figured out
that I was joking. Go off. You guys
might think I'm being mean, but here's
where we arrive at something that I want
to focus on. Oger boy, I I you're
watching this, buddy.
Pay attention to this part, okay? We
figured out where all of the, you know,
there were people coming into the chat.
This is just a total lie, by the way.
You know, everything he's going to say
right here, total lie.
Post the logs, liar. Post the logs,
liar. Post the logs, liar. You're a
liar, Hutch. Hutch, hey Hutch.
You're lying scum. Post the logs, man.
Post the logs right now.
on live and learn, spamming stuff about
my dead sister. And uh ladies and
gentlemen, we got him. So, we know where
that came from.
Um okay, first of all, I'm going to
touch on this one for a moment. Please
do. I'm all ears. Chance Seal Okay
already let it out of the bag. He
admitted that the server existed.
They've been posting uh thumbnails and
[__] of like I said the server existed
like weeks ago, by the way. I literally
said, of course I have a Discord. Of
course I have a clipping Discord. Are
you out of your [__] mind?
Why would you not?
Like I think even Ethan Again, all of
this, Hutch doesn't understand this,
that nobody cares about his dead sister,
right? Like
nobody who's posting about it cares
about his dead sister.
They care about an effective ecosystem
that is countering their messaging,
their
propaganda. They hate it. They hate
having to show up and actually have to
do work. And so, they're trying to turn
it into an existential fight, right?
It's not. We're not going anywhere.
We're totally going to stay in a
business with all the [__] that we've
done in that Discord, right? If
adjustments have to be made, like I've
I've looked through what I can look
through. If adjustments have to be made,
if punishments have to be dealt out,
that'll happen. But, that Discord is not
going anywhere.
This isn't an existential fight for us.
We know that we act correct 99.9% of the
time, and the 0.1% that you're going to
try to pull out
and turn into something is going to
totally blow up in your face.
It will be obvious that you don't hold
any of these standards. It will be
obvious that you don't actually care
about this, and that all you're trying
to do is shut the server down, which is
never going to happen. And Klein put it
in a story uh that like, oh, I'm coming
to find out that there's a server. And
oh, it's got a skull with a CPS etched
into the forehead
for the
the logo, the Discord server. I wonder
what's in there.
I remember it because I was at the gym.
Mhm. And I saw in the combined This was
when they were still putting the chat on
the live and learn
and someone was spamming and they were
jumping between different channels.
>> What can you do?
>> Immediately, I'm like, this is stop.
And I hadn't been in that Discord server
for very long.
And the I did two things right off the
rip because I saw that people in the the
combined chats were like, this is
probably Ogerboy doing it. It's like
that's
And I messaged Pisco immediately and I
go, I'm at the gym. I'm not That's not
me. I'm not [__] doing it. And then I
went over to the the alleged snark
server and I was like, this better not
be any of you people. Like Like don't
even [__] tell me that it's one of
you. Come on, bud. You like you know you
know I have You know I have the logs and
I can I can read the whole conversation.
Like you know that. [__] doing it.
And then I went over to the the alleged
snark server and I was like, this better
not be any of you people. Like Like
don't even tell me that it's one of you.
Come on, bud. You like you know you know
I have You know I have the logs and I
can I can read the whole conversation.
Like Okay, show us the whole
conversation, Hutch. Reproduce the whole
conversation, Hutch. Show me the
conversation.
Show me the conversation.
Wait, just for this part. You're making
this allegation. Show me the
conversation for this part that you
have, you disgusting, lying
sack of [__] Post the logs. Show me
that you're not engaging.
Oh.
I'm going to hold off. I'm going to hold
off. I have to hold back. Show me the
logs, liar.
Liar. Liar. Show me the logs.
>> Like you know that.
Why are you lying about this?
He's just lying about this.
No proof, logs? Let's go, swamp turtle.
Let's go.
Didn't happen.
Not accurate. Not true. He did not say
that.
And I have Oh, is he just saying that
Ogerboy asked if people were saying it
there? There's no Wait, that's even
worse. That's actually so much worse,
isn't it?
Wait, is he trying to say that all that
Ogerboy didn't say it precisely that
way?
What? These are his logs from the
server. These are literally his logs
from the server. Hold on.
Someone was spamming Hutch killed his
sister over and over. People were
blaming me. Dot dot dot. That's not you
guys spamming LNL, is it? So, he
literally asked if people in that server
were spamming
live and learn.
And multiple people say no. Dude, you
are a lying sack of [__] Hutch. You are
a totally despicable
fantastic [__] Oh, that one was close.
Whoa, I almost didn't make it. Jesus
Christ, man.
>> had like three people immediately
respond.
>> is not
precisely what you said." I'm like, "I'm
not doing it. It's not any of us." And
then that was it.
>> Also not true.
Also not true.
>> Wait, what's the what's the follow up
there?
>> about this. I Wait, what's the follow up
Hold on. What What is the follow up
there that that he's saying also not
true? That people didn't say it wasn't
them? I I don't know. Maybe he
uh
He says he has a sleeping disorder.
Maybe he doesn't mem- like remember it.
Uh none of that is true. None of that is
true. And by the time I looked back cuz
I was on my phone, by the time I looked
back, they did they'd already banned the
person and it had stopped. Also not
true. Everything about that is a lie.
And
He's talking about in live and learn
chat. Does Does Ogerboy, or sorry, does
Hutch think that he's saying in the
Snark Discord or something? What's crazy
is like he knows that I can see the
conversation. So, why why Why would you
And I would just you know, like why
would you not assume like at some point
this is probably going to go up in the
internet. You are just lying. I'm just
going to call him a liar right now cuz I
By the way, this is something I looked
into that I like actually did some
searching for. It's I feel like it's
almost impossible that I would have
missed somebody taking responsibility
for this.
But I'm I'm asking somebody find me like
a timestamp right now so I can go look
through my own logs and I'll see.
I will see. I will see.
But that's going to happen. So like why
would you lie about this? He's just like
everything about that was a lie. So I've
never seen cuz it look if there's an
opportunity to talk and and I'll talk
about this more in a minute because I
don't think none of these people
understand the general vibe of like any
of what was happening.
I think people have a good idea
>> [laughter]
>> at this point of what was going on.
Um, but like if I'd seen anything like
that where anyone was admitting to it,
like get the [__] out of here. There's
no shot. There's no shot I would have
[__] tolerated that [__]
And then the other thing was Jason I
This is
>> [snorts]
>> so profoundly dis- dishonest. Hold on.
Hold on. Hold on. What is this?
>> I think people have a good idea
at this point of what was going on.
Um, but like if I'd seen anything like
that where anyone was admitting to it,
like get the [__] out of here. There's
no shot. There's no shot I would have
[__] tolerated that [__]
And then the other thing was Jason I
This is so profoundly dis- dishonest,
you guys. It'll all make sense at some
point
>> I suppose, but the levels of dishonesty
going on here is like like astonishing.
We're not scared.
There's like That's like a four-parter
thing, right? Like First he says he
comes in and and and like grills the
Discord. Like who's doing
[clears throat] this?
Didn't happen.
Then he says
nobody in the Discord No- Nobody in the
Discord like identified like who in the
Discord had been doing the thing. Also
not true.
Then he says he told him to knock it
off. Not true. And then then then here
he says what did he just say? Jsal K
like if I'd seen anything like that
where anyone was admitting to it, like
get the [__] out of here. There's no
shot. There's no profoundly untrue.
That is like the biggest like untrue
thing he said out of all those things.
It's just He's just lying. That is like
the biggest like untrue thing he said
out of all those things. It's just He's
just lying. And you know, that makes
sense because every like every
non-psychotic person on the internet
recognizes that invoking someone's dead
family is just fully un- unhinged. It's
a level of escalation that is just so
far beyond
what would be considered appropriate or
proportionate
in this kind of a situation. People know
that that's unhinged. And you know, he
knows that if he if you know if he
>> spamming your chat would obviously be
unhinged. Yes.
Right?
But it's not I don't believe anybody
spammed your chat, so.
is seen to have like stood by and did
nothing when that kind of stuff was
going on, then that would reflect poorly
on him because it does. It does reflect
poorly on him. If I was on
if I was in Discord in any kind of group
chat
where something like that was happening,
I would be gone immediately. I would
never I would never associate with
people who did stuff like that. Our
friend Oh Did stuff like what? Like spam
that [__] in chats? This is crazy, man.
Your boy here here he made a different
decision when that whole thing went
down. No shot I would have [__]
tolerated Oh, also
you're literally in
you're literally in a community. You go
on a a stream where people do this. What
do we talk about, man? who did that
[__] And then the other thing was Jsal
K made mention that
um
if
uh if he had seen anything about it,
like that's something he wasn't going to
tolerate either. Like it's not like he
was the owner of the server, he's not
into my knowledge. But that They're all
distancing themselves from but like the
point is like that, you know,
was in keeping with the tone of the
whole discord. Like I they're they're
trying to distance themselves
from this particular thing about my dead
sister because it's like just an
an especially egregious example
of like how far gone these people were,
but the tone of like these kind of
attacks was consistent throughout the
whole thing. Like that was the entire
tone of The best part about this is now
people are very very very obviously
saying they didn't do it.
In the server, he's just lying.
And the best part is as I scroll through
this everybody is saying at the same
time that he's a complete who can't
follow an argument or a conversation. So
Little little meta ironies in the chat.
Like this this can't follow No, no, we
wouldn't do that. It's somebody else.
It's got to be somebody else. We would
never do that. Uh this can't even
conversation. That was something that
would like get you banned for sure.
Um but yeah, I don't it's it's not What?
tolerate either.
Like it's not like he was the owner of
the server, he's not into my knowledge.
But that that was something that would
like get you banned for sure.
Nobody got banned for it. Nobody got
banned for this. I don't know what like
I I don't know why he's lying about
this. What a crazy thing to lie about.
Do these people have any [__]
Oh, Hutch thinks See, Hutch is a stupid.
He can't tell that Oger boy is saying
the person got banned from Livin Lard's
chat.
Right? That's obviously what
That's obviously what Oger boy is saying
that the person got banned, right?
into my knowledge. But that that was
something that would like get you banned
for sure.
Nobody got banned for it. Nobody No,
spamming your chat, you stupid
That it's not okay to go spam in your
chat. It's like find a joke about
anything in there, yeah. I have like I
hadn't seen anything like this, but I
wouldn't ban somebody who said, "Oh,
we're making a desk and a hutch or
sister." I wouldn't I wouldn't want
somebody banned who said that in there.
Sorry, you The fact that you lump it
there in together just proves that you
can't follow conversation. That
everything everybody said about you,
that you're a total who can't pay
attention. Yes, that's just true. But he
got banned for this. I don't know what
like I I don't know why he's lying about
this. What a crazy thing to lie about.
Do these people have any integrity? Like
an ounce of integrity. Well, yeah. Yeah,
we would we would not ban somebody for a
joke in the server. I would go, "Hey,
that's weird. You're a weirdo." Right?
But I I don't think people would be
banned for it. Yeah. I don't It's It's
not coming To my knowledge, it was
Hey, there's got to be like four or five
different logs in that server of me
going, "Hey, this is weirdo behavior.
Hey, this weirdo behavior."
It's me casting judgment on people, but
I don't think principally they shouldn't
be allowed to say that's like crazy.
You know what I mean?
Realistically, by the way, that's
they're saying it to themselves. Like I
I like people talking to themselves in
the Discord or times where I've said
that.
>> coming from anybody that I was aware of.
Just like bald-faced lie. Blatant lie.
Like just unambiguous lie. I find it
very interesting
that
you know, a
a few people
have been trying to like tar and feather
me
for the company I keep from time to
time.
And they're in there sharing in a
Discord not pushing back whatsoever. Not
true. Uh Completely not true. True. It
is true. Travacchio with $5. If any of
these snarkers found you
There it is. It Wait, is he I'm sure
somebody's pushed back on the hutch
sister thing. I know that literally it
was pushed back on when we had the vote
thing that I showed yesterday.
But he's just lying. This will be a
really interesting test to see how
effective these like open and obvious
lies are.
If you're just trying to stay silent to
see who's in the right, like you should
be asking for proof. If people want to
want to say this is happening, they're
making claims, ask them for proof.
If you're just waiting back waiting
holding back while these people slander
us,
I'm going to keep track.
Mostly without being able to do anything
about it, but you know,
just in case you ever ask me to buy you
a drink one day.
Is it an attempt to say anyone that
mocks him for his relation to Destiny is
a hypocrite? Oh. Who was a doxer, it's
crazy and hypocritical.
I would never in a thousand years ever
be in a Discord like that. Ever. Okay.
Are you kidding me? I am an adult
person, reasonably well adjusted, I
would say.
Like I
I don't know what to say. Like I'm
getting pretty close to crashing out and
I like
I Why would I do that? Why would I
associate with like that level of
degeneracy? That's not true. Also, it's
not a cult, so it's a flippering, but
whatever. Uh when you had people bring
up my deceased sister. Uh paranoid
android
with the tier one membership. Thank you.
It kind of makes sense that they're
trying to distance them themselves from
it because it's just like that's such a
crazy thing to do, bro. It's a crazy
thing to do and it's a crazy thing to
just like not like self-police
in the context of everybody else that
was in the Discord, you know, it just
gives you a sense of like how they
operated. Just all the time, you know,
and like
talking about spam in chat. Um that's
interesting. That's an interesting
situation there. I hate political ideas.
I hate being chicken [__] I hate people
that that
I don't want anything uh to to happen to
these people. I don't want anybody to
harass them. I argue about things. I
want to talk about why these people are
full of [__] I want to use them as
object lesson to say don't be like this
person. But there's at no point in here
have I been like hit this person with
any Like that's not that's never the way
that I have ever ever ever carried
myself
ever.
So but he did this
He said got to say I'm not terribly
surprised to have found this in the Are
you denying?
Like what what's what's what's your
issue with cropping out the name? Are
you denying that it's real? Is that what
you're denying? I mean cuz you just
talked about it for
last like 10 minutes uh seemingly
acknowledging that it was real. The
leaked snark Discord logs. Folks, this
is online politics. If you're invoking
dead family members over this stuff,
you're years overdue for extensive
therapy. Delete your accounts and
re-evaluate. Asmongold is happy people
getting fired. So if you said JD Vance
Asmongold's dead mom, Asmongold would
defend it. Asmongold if his dead mom,
Asmongold blew up his mom.
Oh wait wait wait wait wait wait. Wait
wait wait. A reminder that Asmongold
killed his mom by handing her a
cigarette which blew up her ventilator
cinema. Asmongold seconds before pro
clutching over his dead mom. So you have
Asmongold, he's supposed to have a
beautiful picture of his mom right
before she set herself on fire. Feels
strong man.
This is your mom and Asmongold viewer
now.
LOL cry about your dead dad some more
Destiny. LOL cry about your dead dad
some more
Asmongold Twitch version of Gerbils
Destiny. I don't want to offend him
by commenting on his mom.
Asmongold, how is your mom doing? Hey
Asmongold, where's your mom buddy?
Uh-oh.
Seems like this would be the community
you wouldn't want to draw from, right?
Probably, if I had to guess.
Yeah, it's just it's weird for me,
right? It's pretty weird that Hutch
would associate with people and
communities that do this, right? The
creator who does this Destiny's done it
directly. No?
I I don't think it matters. Like I'm I
think Hutch is Hutch is fully aware of
who Destiny is. Like all of that all of
that that he is everything he's calling
out right now. He's fully aware Dessy's
like that and he just doesn't care.
Right? He is He is just lying about this
to other people. He's just trying to get
in good with that audience. It's
transparent. It's obvious. It's sad.
Obviously.
So, they cut off whoever the [__] this
was. Now, could be anybody. If you were
to put the name associated with it, this
is why this to me
First of all, it would be a screen name.
Okay? It's not like it would be the real
name of the person, but it would be a
screen name.
If someone like that was doing something
like that, I think that there would
probably be a level of value in at least
putting the screen name there. Because
the other part of this is going to be
you want the people that own the server
to be able to go, "No, we saw that and
we [__] banned them."
You want to be able to go, "That was a
[__] person. It was a shaky person on
This just This is so far from the truth.
I don't know if he's diluted himself.
Maybe he's memory holed it because
because of the shame and the guilt. Uh
but this is so far beyond the truth.
>> whatever They were on thin ice. We saw
that they did this [__] and then we
[__] banned them.
But you can't do that because you're not
including the name. I wouldn't mind
admitting to this that I was behind
something like this, but this isn't what
I do. I've never been like this. When
this [__] occurred,
I was telling them in the [__] in one
of the in the main channel. I'm like,
To be clear, kind of wanted to [__] with
them a little bit, but if you guys are
going to force my hand on this,
he's not the one who did that.
Just to be clear.
He's not the one who did that. If I was
giving off that impression,
that's not what I intended. But But
everything he's saying is so so far from
the reality of how that all like went
down. He's just lying like lying about
it like blatantly lying about it. And
get the [__] out of here. Like you
better not be one of you guys doing this
cuz I was still relatively new, but I
was like, "No, [__] that." That's one,
but two, it's just weird. It's it's just
so like even more pathetic because it's
like I don't I don't know. Is he
diluting himself? The levels of like
patheticness just across this whole
everything that we've react to so far is
just so profound, but like now he's like
crafting this head cannon where he like
stood up. You know, I was new to the
group, but I spoke up anyways. And it's
just like none of it is true. None of
that is true.
He's just lying about this, but is he Is
he lying to himself? Does he believe his
own lies? Who knows? I have no idea. to
me. Like why would you not include
This right here would give the other
people that were in there or that might
have been in there the ability to go,
"No, no, no. We complained about that
person and they got banned."
Like I don't I don't
I have faults with that I have issue
with this. A lot of slurs. He has issue
with He has issue with this because it
just
really reflects poorly on, you know,
that that level of degeneracy was going
on and there was no policing of that of
this of this this particular thing.
There was no policing of it at all. I
got to say a lot a lot of slurs. Like I
mean slurs, you guys. Uh the bad ones.
Like the very very bad ones. Lot of
slurs. Interesting. Interesting about
that. He's pretty quiet about that.
Do you actually care about slurs, Hutch?
The guy who played Call of Duty for so
long, you care about slurs?
>> much.
In a in an invite-only space, you care
about slurs?
Really? In an invite-only space, you
care about slurs? Why?
I just don't What is the virtue say? Why
are you like virtue signaling at slurs
right now? Why would you pretend you
care about this?
You can't possibly care about this.
>> Of all the people he you know, he he
definitely You know, a lot of these
people are kind of like nihilists, you
know? Like I don't know if
You get the sense Our chief complaint
with you is that you are a cynical
defeated whiny weepy
How in the world are you arguing we're
nihilistic? that ideology is not the
thing that's like driving these people
or even politics. Maybe it has like the
facade of that, but really it's about
like
personal spite and whatever.
But him in particular, like he he
definitely presents himself as like this
like Uber Uber woke person, right? Like
Uber like progressive person. Well, you
know, Lonerbox
apparently had a little mole
in a secret snarker Discord with 100
plus people. I think it's uh Is it a
secret Discord if there's 100 people in
it? We covered the DGG big screen thing
last Did you ever talk about it before?
They got exposed.
Yes. We literally talked about it
openly, said obviously I'm in a clipping
Discord
like weeks ago.
Yeah.
Yep. Had no problem saying it. I'm just
like, "Are you going to tell me you
don't have any Might have been reacting
to Destiny. Are you going to say you
don't have any Discords like this?" I'm
like, "Bro, I got a clipping Discord.
And I know that people have been banned
from that Discord and are really mad
about it and talk about it in other
places. I'm not hiding it anywhere."
Yeah, we got a We got a clipping
Discord. What's the problem? What is the
charge?
>> Exposed. Did anyone publicly talk about
it before it got exposed?
>> No, I mean I mean that's technically an
out in the open channel, but if nobody
knows it's there, then it's still a
secret. It's still some place where
hundreds, if not thousands, of people
snark on content creators at any given
moment. So like, I mean, you know, what
are It's all It's all Dude, that was a
big face. That was a big set of faces.
>> place where hundreds, if not thousands,
of people snark on content creators
at any given moment.
So
like,
I mean,
you know, what are
It's all
It's all semantics.
Thousands? I don't know about that.
Here's the other thing. They're going to
drip feed this It's the most obvious
thing in the world at this point.
They're in as opposed to if Well, you
know, kind of make Uh Marmaduke and get
$10 Oh, sorry. Marmaduke and SpaceGhost.
Thank you very much for the gifted subs,
guys. Thank you, thank you, thank you.
>> Make sense. They wanted to say like
these people are [__] up and here you
go. And Uh Zixen and the Wixen with $2.
Thanks for creating all this delicious
chaos. I didn't create this. I didn't
create this. Don't rope me into this. I
did not consent to this. And then they
would just dump the whole thing online,
call it a day. But they're not going to
do that. There's no There's no drama in
that. There's no They want to They want
to drip drip drip. And then they also
want to be able to like selectively
redact I know Why would the fact that
this is secret be scary? Isn't it the
things that are being said in there that
are bad?
The fact that it's secret does nothing.
The fact that it's like invite-only does
literally nothing. What are we talking
about? Some people are arguing now
apparently that the fact that it was
secret is bad.
What Why? No, I Oh, yeah, he's got the
logs, but he's Why do you think it's
secret? Oh, cuz it's like
cuz some of the people we're talking
about have shown an open propensity to
dox anybody critical of them. Maybe
that? Might that be why it was secret in
the first place? Why it was invite-only?
Because the people who get criticized,
the same people who are complaining
about it now, are the same people that
we were looking to avoid the scrutiny
of. We didn't want to get doxed by. What
do you think?
He's not going to do it either. Oh, by
the way, I don't even know I don't think
that's why it was made in the first
place.
But that's what it became very quickly.
Right? I think when it first I don't
even know what it was meant to be when
it like when they first made it. I don't
know what the thought was.
I actually have I don't know the history
of the chat.
If this was an unhinged across-the-board
situation, you would just dump the whole
thing. You would put it somewhere on a
website and just call it a day.
>> [laughter]
>> You just said that there's like a drip
drip drip thing going on, right? Like
And then people could go and look and
consider for themselves. The one of the
Hold on. We're not there yet. I want to
let him talk for a little bit more. And
uh offered, you know, said I I could pay
him $20,000 to get my hands on the logs,
and I thought it was a fair deal. So,
you know what? Let's do it.
There's no way There That has to be a
meme. That's the saddest thing in the
world if he did do that. I kind of feel
like he probably is not joking, but I'm
just for sake of his The level of brain
rot. own mental health insanity, I
really hope that he didn't Cuz LonerBox
was saying on his stream that somebody
paid 20 grand, and he's admitting to it.
Mhm, I think Loner Yeah, Ogre Boy
probably misheard it, or maybe didn't
watch the whole clip. I think LonerBox
was very obviously joking when he said
that.
I
Sometimes when I hold out hope on a
human being, okay? That's so
That It had But it But it has to be.
wonky, it has to be. Jesus Christ.
Because if he did pay that much money,
first of all, that means Loner hates
him. Like that would mean Loners Like
Hutch is a joke to him. As opposed to
being something that they Like they they
together, [laughter] they've
collaborated in the past.
Just the really like particularly stupid
attempt at like sewing division. And
Wait, wouldn't that you pay $20,000 for
it?
He's saying that Loner would obviously
be an
If you paid If he made you pay $20,000
for it, he would like think you're
particularly stupid.
Like He actually can't follow the
conversation. He doesn't even know
what's being said. Oh, you said LonerBox
thinks I'm dumb. That's all that
happened here.
Like Yeah, again, the Hutch RAM is just
very, very compressed, okay? He's got
like 4 kilobytes of RAM. So, if you talk
long enough If you talk for more than
like 5 to 10 seconds at a time, he just
Like he starts to lose context in the
conversation. He just can't maintain it
all at the same time. You're just You're
You're
overfilling the stack, okay? Stack
overflow. It's over. He's crashing. He's
blue screened. This is the most exciting
thing that's happened to any of them in
a long time, and because of the This is
1,000% the most exciting thing that's
happened to him in probably years. way
that they're going to decide to release
the information in maybe the weeks and
even months to come, they're going to be
able to keep this going forward.
Who knows? I don't know. Who knows?
You're not going to be able to talk
about him while he talks about his son,
cuz he's going to say, "Why are you
making fun of a tiny little creator like
me?" He's going to be like, "I'm just a
small being, you guys. Why are you
making fun of me, Jebediah Hutch?"
Joseph Jebediah Hutchinson, I
understand, and I'm not sure I and the
one thing I was saying a lot in the
early goings was like, I'm not trying to
yuck anybody's yum, okay? I'm not trying
to do that. I go, "But here's the thing,
what you're doing isn't politics. It's
not. You're treating this like it's a
reality TV show." And that's kind of the
way That's kind of the way a lot of the
people in there were doing it, right?
And
Oh my god.
The absolute sheer amount of projection
on display. Any I think like it for the
I didn't What? Ogre Boy doesn't treat it
like a reality TV show. He is sincerely
engaged. He sincerely watches a lot of
political stuff. He sincerely follows
and reads a lot of stuff. And then when
he engages in conversations, he does a
little kayfabe cuz he's a wrestling
fault like he's a wrestling fan. He does
a little kayfabe. He tries to ham it up
for fun. That's not a reality TV show.
That's him like sincerely engaging and
then doing a performance. You can do
both of those things without it being
reality TV, man. It was people treating
it like that, but it's also doing a lot
of the [__] that Sargon has talked about
incessantly. It's using content creators
as the lens for politics.
Guys, guys, don't you realize? I'm just
imagining him like lecturing. Guys,
don't you realize you're not actually
doing politics? Don't you know? But
also, we're kind of using content
creators as a vehicle for politics. It's
like
What?
I'm not that deep. Like you can do it.
I'm guilty of it two times, but that
then why are you lecturing people about
this? This guy is like a caricature,
man. That's all this ever was. So when
he's talking about this [__] hey, that
thing that you're doing, you can do it,
but it doesn't matter. Nothing matters.
I don't matter. You can go volunteer at
a soup kitchen instead. Am I going to do
that? No. Am I going to continue to
argue with you guys about the same
thing? I can do the same thing that
you're doing exactly, like literally
exactly. Yes, but let me just lecture
you about that real quick. This guy is
insufferable. I want you to think
He's saying that it doesn't have an
impact that he has fun doing it. He
enjoys it immensely, but that it's not
having the impact he that a lot of
people think they're having. If you
think you're doing politics, that's one
thing. But if you're treating these No,
you know what? We got to call him Ari
Shaffir. That's how we're going to get
around his his searches of himself. No
more mention of Ogre Boy so he can't go
to his website and figure out when we
talked about him. He's going to be Ari
Shaffir from now on.
These
Like even that even that just shows like
a critical
lack of capacity. Like that is the level
of intel Hutch when he hears that
there's a website where you can search
transcripts, he doesn't understand. He
actually can't put these concepts
together that you would just be able to
search a new word. Like he's not
intelligent enough to just bring that in
automatically. He can't like it just
doesn't even register that that is like
abstract concepts. Oh, you have
something where you can search and then
we're going to call him a different word
than ogre boy. So when he searches ogre
boy, he won't find it anymore. But you
just said it in a video about ogre boy.
Like what do you think the odds are that
ogre boy wouldn't see this? You've said
yourself you think he'll see this.
So like somehow in his head that is a
website that lets you search for
mentions of ogre boy. Like he just
doesn't nothing clicks in this dome of
his. It's just it's impenetrable. It's
so thick it's impenetrable. These people
like they're they're reality TV
characters now you're all like oh This
is actually even better point chat pity.
He literally said the ogre boy mention
and Arya Stark within seconds of each
other. So they're going to be within the
same time stamp in whatever transcript
there is. His website he also called it
his website too. It's this guy is
kind of foundationally I wonder if any
of these DGGers like think about this.
Like hey, dude this guy like actually
can't understand this at all. Like he's
actually really dumb.
He doesn't get it. You're wasting your
time. None of this matters. I do it too.
Just know that what you're doing doesn't
matter. But I but also I do it too. I
know what I'm like you know what is
going on right now because it kind of
involves me in some respect and I know
you you're going to ask me about this
[__] So I don't mind talking about it
now that the cat's out of the bag. But
other than this, I've said if he's
talking about the DOJ I don't give a
[__] If he's talking about Trump,
that's good. Talk about Trump. Talk
about Trump all day. If you want to talk
about like do dumb content about Hasan,
I don't watch any dish content about
Hasan. I don't really give He watches He
watches everything. Little Arya Stark
watches everything. When he's trying to
defend what Kamala did, Oh yes,
especially watches it when he's covering
Hasan drama. Or when he's flying about
Gaza. Then I get mad and I can't help
myself and I'm going to do exactly what
we're doing right now. But that's it.
But outside of that, I don't give a They
hit me at a time when I'm like, "Oh, I'm
looking for a new group of people with
when I'm not at [__] work." And then
this is what occurred. Straight up.
Literally that's what happened. Just the
most believable thing he's ever said.
Like everything about that lines up.
Yeah, that sounds about right. I got to
say, if I had to imagine what that
trajectory looked like, definitely looks
like that. That was That was how I got
in and that was what I noticed. It's
just reality TV shows. It is It's a lot
It's a lot to unpack. We're going to end
it there. You know, I just I just Let's
just put a bow on that one. I don't know
Let's just put a perfect end to that
one. I mean, just like very rarely do
you get such a insightful look into the
mind.
I
>> [sighs]
>> Boy, oh boy, oh boy, buddy. Boy, oh boy.
There's like if only only I could go
into specifics.